diese kleine tasche an der energy
verstehe ich immer meinen wurde denn das
passt perfekt rein panoro name ist luca
und ich habe einen artikel im internet
gefunden meine damen und herren der den
titel trägt 25 alltäglichen dinge von
denen du nicht wusstest wozu sie gut
sind und da habe ich mir gedacht
kann das wirklich sein wird es derrick
entspricht das der warte ich wirklich
nicht die bedeutung verdient 26 dieser
frage meine damen und herren widmen wir
uns in diesem heutigen video hast du
gedacht dass das loch im deckel den
kugelschreiber vom austrocknen bewahrt
also hier ist jetzt ein kugelschreiber
abgebildet und hier so einen deckel
online-konten roter pfeil klick bett
hast du gedacht dass das loch fielen
deckel in den kugelschreiber vom
austrocknen bewahrt oder das ist für den
druckausgleich da ist damit der
kugelschreiber nicht aus
doch der eigentliche grund für das loch
ist viel viel interessanter das kleine
loch im kunststoff deckel sind die
gefahr einer erstickung
der partie überhaupt keinen sinn das
mini loch am flugzeug scheiben ich denke
die meisten unter uns sind irgendwie
schon mal geflogen ich bin nun mal aus
der schule geflogen
auf jeden fall befindet sich an den
fenstern immer so ein loch und hier
steht jetzt dieses klitzekleine loch hat
gleich zwei großartige funktionen oder
ich kann es gar nicht erwarten erstes
dient das loch dem druckausgleich denn
wenn das flugzeug höher steigt er steht
ein druckunterschied zwischen dem
flugzeug innern und der umgebung das
loch ist die verbindung von der äußeren
und der mittel sind wir hier bei 46 24
oder watt also einmal aufgrund des
drucks gleich so ein zweiter schützt das
loch die scheiben vorn geschlagen
ersetzt sie quasi atmen also danke loch
denn durch dich können die scheiben
atmen eine ganz kurze sache hier eben
zwischendrin meine damen und herren und
zwar habe ich ja meine damen und herren
wir haben jetzt klasse musik haben staat
ich habe einen neuen kanal
die begeisterung ist jetzt nicht so
krass vorhanden sie findet ganz oben in
der beschreibung einen link eingeblendet
und zwar führt euch dieser link zu
meinem neuen kanal namens luca stories
und zwar werden auf diesem kanal
wöchentlich meine instagram stories vom
den tagen der letzten woche hochgeladen
falls sie also irgendwann mal eine story
von mir verpasst haben solltet weil ich
irgendwie im urlaub hat oder weil er
grabherr netz hatte oder weil ihr
einfach keine zeit hat oder weil ich mir
auch vielleicht einfach nicht auf
instagram oder snapshot oder so folgt
dann könnt ihr einfach wöchentlich auf
den kanal gehen und euch dort meine
story der letzten sieben tage anschauen
die videos werden dort im hochformat
hochgeladen also ich könnte euch
wirklich das ganze so anschauen und das
wird dann quasi angezeigt wie auch in
meiner instagram story das ganze
angezeigt wurde und ja ihr könnt jetzt
einfach hier oben auf die infoguard
klicken und da könnt ihr auf den neuen
kanal gehen ich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr dann aber da lassen würde und
das erste video sogar schon online also
meine story der letzten sieben tage aber
jetzt machen wir weiter mit diesen
komischen live hacks das extra
stoffstück in deinen neuen klamotten ist
doch klar wenn irgendwie was reißt was
man sich gekauft hat oder ein loch hat
oder so dann kann man das damit halt
flicken und zunehmend du hast bestimmt
immer gedacht dass diese stoff tempel
zum flicken von löchern oder so da sind
oder ja genau richtig falsch
denn der eigentliche sind von diesen
stoffproben du kannst damit testen wie
der stoffe verschiedene waschmittel
reagiert der macht denn so was diese
kleine tasche an deiner jeans habe ich
auch da verstehe ich immer mein niveau
drin das passt perfekt rein als die
jeans erfunden wurde also als es den
wilden westen noch gab die fünfte tasche
absolut unverzichtbar sie war nämlich
der aufbewahrungsort für die taschenuhr
der cowboys und goldgräber
ich kenne keinen menschen der in dieser
tasche seine taschenuhr hat die ganzen
nieten an der jeans hose als levi
strauss seine erste jeans zur zeit des
wilden westens herstellte hatte er ein
großes problem die nähte der hose rissen
immer unter dem schweren gewicht der
goldnuggets yaman ich trage auch immer
goldnuggets weil mir wozu sollen denn
diese zwei löcher in chucks gut sein
damit sie besser durchlüftet werden und
eine füße nicht stinken ja hätte also
hätte ich jetzt gedacht nein der grund
für die löcher ist ein ganz anderer
ursprünglich ist der legendäre converse
all star ein basketball schuhe und jetzt
haben die löcher plötzlich einen super
sinn einen ein super sind keine normalen
super sind diese zwei löcher sind dazu
da den schuh beim spielen enger schnüren
zu können um ihnen nicht zu verlieren
ich kenne keinen anderen schuh der
löcher braucht damit man sie nicht
verliert wenn man sie an hier wird
gesagt warum man so maaß bändern oft so
ein kleines loch ist das weiß ich aber
schon und zwar ist das wirklich dazu da
damit man so ein nagel kopf also wenn
man irgendwie einen nagel hatte man wir
messen wie weiter runter geht dann kann
man das daran festmachen
ich bin handwerker und ein maßband kann
noch so viel mehr sie dir nur bei dieser
geriffelte kante an dass jetzt diese
kante und damit kann man dann wohl
irgendwas in die wand machen oder so
aber warum sie so kann der so zackig und
wofür soll das gut sein überlege mal
genau du mist etwas es ist eng und du
hast beide hände voll zu tun ich habe
immer weiter eine weiße soutane
verdammte ausrauben
das habe ich gesagt jetzt musst du was
mag ihren hass aber keinen stift zur
hand mit der geriffelten kannte kannst
du eine kleine markierung hinterlassen
indem du sie zum beispiel einfach etwas
an einer wand treibst
und das ist meine wand kaputt ist doch
ein loch im topspiel
also das können wir uns anhand des
bildes eigentlich schon erklären da kann
man dann kochlöffel reinstecken und dann
tropft er hier ein ja klar kannst du das
loch auf verwenden und einen topf gegen
wo dranzuhängen
wer hängt sich ein topf denn irgendwo
hin habt ihr irgendwo schon mal eine
küche gesehen wo töpfer an der wand
hängen ein kleiner faymann tankanzeige
kommen das weiß doch jedes kind das ist
die seite wo der tank ist das ist halt
ganz geil wenn man irgendwie sich ein
auto ausgeliehen hat oder so und dann
weiter kämen mustang und dann fährt man
auf die tankstelle zu dann kann man
kurzer ein koop und dann sieht man ok
falsch jetzt rechts wo man die tanks
oder links rum da ja allerdings
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch
unter 18 sind werdet ihr das noch nicht
so richtig wissen dieses erkannte bei
einer haarnadel das habe ich mich schon
immer gefragt warum steht die so fett
unten die es unten nicht da der grund
ist eigentlich ein ganz einfacher viele
haarnadel haben eine geriffelte und eine
glatte seite die geriffelte sollte zur
kopfhaut zeigen da die haarnadel dadurch
einen besseren griff in den haaren
behält
das ist alles das loch in der spaghetti
keller also ich denke sind uns alle
einig dass es dafür da ist wenn man sich
nudeln nimmt dass das wasser durch
abläuft aber welcher mensch steckt seine
nudeln denn dadurch
6 eine nudel dadurch ein kleines loch in
vielen vorhängeschlössern das
interessiert eigentlich niemanden dieses
dicke stück an einigen kabeln das habe
ich mich wirklich schon voll häufig
gefragt dann voll vielen kabeln ist
einfach so ein fettes ding dran hier die
kurze erklärung dieser zylinder artige
knüppel heißt verriet kern
fällt kann und muss an einigen kabeln
dran sein um geräte mit hochfrequenten
störungen zu unterdrücken zum beispiel
deinen computer wie das alles genau
funktioniert kannst du dir gerne hier
mal durchlesen ich würde sagen als ich
mir jetzt mal ganz kurz darauf mal
schauen wo wir dahin kommen
hier geht es um gegen eine rote kappe
offen plastikkorken von einer
sektflasche oder so aber da wir alle
kein alkohol trinkt müssen uns was ich
auch nicht angucken
weißt du was du mit diesem endstück
eines cuttermesser machen kannst nie
vielleicht essen für einen snack
zwischendurch wenn du es nicht weiß dann
verrate ich jetzt mal mensch das ist ja
richtig freundlich von dir dass du es
mit unserem beitrag oder dann verrät das
wäre so wie wenn ich sage jetzt gibt man
merchandise im luca - shop.de und dann
gibt es dort noch wirklich mein
merchandise das ist ja unfassbar ist dir
aufgefallen dass dieses messer ganz
viele einzelne klingen besitzt das es so
damit du jede einzelne klinge abbrechen
kannst wenn sie stumpf wird und damit du
dich nicht verletzt kannst du bei deinem
cuttermesser den hinteren teil sogar
abnehmen und auf die klingen setzen dann
einfach abbrechen und du hast wieder ein
scharfes messer
wer benutzt so oft einen kater dass
diese klingen stumpf werden diese kleine
spitze im deckel
das ist dazu da damit man das ab
schraubt und dagegen drückt damit die
creme rauskommt weil das ja noch
verschlossen damit sie länger haltbar
ist also wird das die mir das erklären
dass die denken wirklich ich bin
komplett dummen da kann ich den
natürlich auch eigentlich recht geben
und diese kleinen knubbel auf jeder
tastatur das ist dazu da damit man beim
zehnfingersystem sich orientieren kann
ich kenne das alles schon bedacht zu
dieser erhebungen für menschen die das
10 finger schreiben beherrschen diese
knüppel auf den tasten 11 die hatten
sich übrigens orientierungslos
anfänglich habe man sonst den finger
schreiben kurz gemacht und tippe jetzt
einfach wieder komplett anders ein loch
in jedem lineal aber warum zum aufhängen
was sollte ich doch ohne diesen beitrag
machen eigentlich müsste eine rebecca
wegen darüber mal ein video machen und
so sagen wow cavus ja als auch gerade
das schöne grüße gehen raus an dich hast
du dich auch mal gefragt warum du diese
dinge an einem mac next
raus verweilt man damit das kabel auf
rollen also ich meine das ist hier
natürlich auch schon aber ich würde euch
jetzt bei ladekabel zeigt euch das ja
schon wusste
2000 jahre später dreimal dürft ihr
raten werk gerade innerhalb von 2000
jahren nicht sein ladekabel gefunden hat
oder was dieser kleine schwarze punkte
auf einem iphone eigentlich ist das loch
ist ein zusätzliches mikrofon ich dachte
körper seine drogen darin lagern weißt
du wie du richtig tick tack ist
fast vergessen hätte ich diese kleinen
mensch zum glück hatten nicht vergessen
dass hier sind so plastik blättchen die
im deckel einer wasserflasche sind diese
dinge kennt zu bestimmen jeder hat die
doch mal daraus gefummelt was ich habe
die teile dann noch nie herausgefunden
ich mache eigentlich wasser verstellbar
auf um das wasser zu trinken und nicht
um den deckel auseinander zu nehmen ja
und dann haben wir die flasche wieder
verschlossen und uns gewundert dass da
ohne das plastik welchen wasser raus
läuft wenn die flasche umfeld der grund
diese kleinen unscheinbaren blättchen
sind dichtungen oder sie würden die
meisten flaschen nicht nur auslaufen
sondern hätten auch einige keine
kohlensäure
ich glaube ich kann ich lesen ich kann
nicht lesen
diese mysteriöse blaue seite vom
radiergummi also sorry buzzfeed aber das
steht sogar hier drauf also das hier ist
für bleistift und das ist für
kugelschreiber weil das ein bisschen
rauer als ich verspreche dir damit
kannst du wirklich tinte radieren aber
was fehlt ist der hinweis dass du
unbedingt sehr starkes und dickes papier
dafür benutzen sonst denn die blaue
seite trägt mehr papier ab als die
weichere rote seite genau deshalb hast
du mit der blauen seite auch mal gerne
ein loch ins papier also bei meinem
bizeps kann ich auch mit der roten seite
in loch ins papier radieren meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gibt mir gern
mal in die kommentare was ihr von den
dingen die ich euch jetzt gezeigt habe
wirklich schon wusste und was jetzt für
euch was neues ist was euch eventuell
dem nächstes leben retten könnte und die
zu beginn schon gesagt ich habe neuen
kanal auf dem jetzt auch meine in story
hochgeladen wird also wenn ihr mir nicht
auf instagram folgt was eh schon eine
schlechte idee sich heißt nämlich laser
luca aber dann könnt ihr jetzt auch den
youtube-kanal lukas tories abonnieren
wie gesagt einmal einer woche kommt dann
video
jetzt glaube ich packen